- Let's get to the judicial reform.
Ever since this judicial
reform was proposed back
in January, this country has
been in a state of turmoil.
You paused this legislation
in order to allow
for talks with the opposition
because you were worried,
like many people in the
country, each sides fighting
for each other could
descend into a civil war.
But those talks with the
opposition now have broken down
and you say you may advance
this legislation unilaterally.
Are you not willing to return
to the talks with the opposition at all?
Will you just continue now
to unilaterally pass this legislation?
- Well, I definitely
sought a broad consensus
and possibly in a formal
agreement with the opposition.
But what we discovered after I pushed
the pause button after one month
and two months and three
months, that the opposition
was under such political pressures
that they couldn't agree to
the most minimal understanding.
They couldn't agree to
things that we brought up
by the opposition leaders before
they went into opposition.
- Can you be more specific, though?
What would you changed
from the original proposal
from this measured proposal?
What will be different?
- Well, I already changed a few things
right after the original
proposal was put forward.
I said that the idea of an override clause
where the parliament the Knesset
can override the decisions
of the supreme court
with a simple majority.
I said, I threw that out, basically.
- That's not coming back at all?
- You're not following this.
People don't know, they
just don't follow me.
- Well, we thought it might come back
with a super majority.
- No, I said it's out.
- Okay.
- And it's very clear that
the way of choosing judges,
it's not gonna be the current structure,
but it's not gonna be
the original structure.
- Let's talk about Iran's
relationship with Russia.
Iran is now supplying Russia
with drones that it uses
in Ukraine and Russia has
a deal with Iran to supply
it with fighter jets, combat helicopters.
Russia is helping Iran advance
its cyber capabilities,
potentially its missile
production facilities.
How does this new relationship
between Iran and Russia
change the relationship
between Israel and Russia?
- Well, it's a very disturbing
relationship, obviously,
partnership, because it
gives Iran the weapons
or the means to advance its
goals against Israel and others,
against the Arab states
and against many others.
And it also, Iran is
supplying Russia with weapons
that are used in the war of
Ukraine with deadly effect.
So obviously, we're concerned with that.
We've made our concerns
known to the Russians.
We are also helping
Ukraine, we're helping them
in civilian defense, an
alert civilian alert system
that prevents, that will obviate the need
to get half the country in
shelters for every missile fired.
So we're helping them with that,
but we're making our concerns
to the Russian government.
- What did
Moscow say back?
Can you share that with us?
- Well, I think they're
aware of our concerns
and I think it's important to understand
that we are concerned also with
the possibility that systems
that we would give to Ukraine would fall
into Iranian hands and
could be reverse engineered
and we would find ourselves
facing Israeli systems used
against Israel.
And by the way, that's
not a theoretical system,
a theoretical threat
because Western system,
anti-tank systems, for example,
did exactly that journey
and we now find them on
our borders with Hezbollah.
Remember, Israel is a country
the size of New Jersey.
It's been pelted with 20,000,
more than 20,000 rockets,
in a very densely populated country.
And we haven't had many
casualties for one reason
because Iron Dome shoots down 95%
of the missiles that enter our,
it could hit our populated centers.
Now, if that system were to
fall in the hands of Iran,
then millions of Israelis
would be left defenseless
and imperiled.
- Are you aware of what
the Ukrainian ambassador
to Israel said recently
that Israel says its stance is neutral
about this conflict
between Ukraine and Russia.
But he said in reality, it's pro-Russia.
He said that Israel
really hadn't delivered
on its promises regarding aid to Ukraine.
How do you respond to those assertions
by the Ukrainian ambassador?
- Well, that's not true.
The former government made some promises
which were in the process.
Well, they weren't delivered,
but I delivered them.
And I think people know,
maybe you should find out what's going on,
but we're not neutral.
We've expressed our sympathy
and our position with Ukraine.
But I'm saying there is a
limit, limitations that we have.
and concerns and interests that we have.
And my first interest,
regardless of sympathy
and the steps that we take
is to ensure the security
of the one and only Jewish state.
And we have the concerns that I told you.
We are also, our pilots
are flying right next
to Russian pilots over the skies of Syria
in order to block the attempts of Iran
to establish a second
Hezbollah front in Syria.
- Is there any indication
that the Iranians
are trying to build a nuclear bomb itself,
a nuclear warhead?
- Well, there is more than indication
because I sent the Mossad
to the heart of Tehran
and they brought back Iran's
secret nuclear archive.
And the opening document
of that archive said
that Iran's purpose 20
years ago, 21 years ago,
in 2003, was to build five kiloton bombs.
That's five Hiroshima bombs.
That's 21 years ago.
So you can assume that they
haven't abandoned this goal.
- But is there evidence
that they're reviving
that project today?
- Well, they certainly
have revived that project
in the sense that they're
moving all the time
with enrichment, as you said,
which is a critical component
of making a nuclear bomb.
It's not the only component.
There's also the weaponization group,
there's also the missile group.
- Can you tell us us what's happening
with the weaponization group?
- I could, but I won't.
- The US is now re-engaging
diplomatically with Iran,
quote a mini deal around
its nuclear program.
Do you think this so-called
mini deal is the first stage
in reviving the old Iran deal,
or do you think the old
Iran deal is really dead?
- Any deal with Iran that doesn't set back
their nuclear infrastructure,
that doesn't, basically, take
it apart is not very useful.
Khomeini just said, "Well,
I'm willing to enter a deal.
I just will not roll back
any of the infrastructure."
He said that about the mini deal
and he wants to get money,
he's gonna get billions.
So I think that's a bad deal.
Obviously, a deal which would
give them hundreds of billions
of dollars and would enable
them within two years,
three years, in what is
called the sunset clause
to remove all limitations
on the nuclear enrichment
is a far worse deal.
So look, maximum deal or mini deal,
neither is going to stop us
from doing what we need to do
to defend Israel against a regime
that openly says it's out to destroy us,
and is seeking to achieve
the means to do so.
So we will do whatever is
necessary to defend ourselves.
- You've known President Biden
now for over four decades,
you've friendly relationship,
but since the establishment
of your new government,
you haven't received
an invitation to the White House.
Some of your senior
ministers can't get meetings
with the Biden administration as well.
What does that say
about the current nature
of the relationship between
Israel and the United States?
- Well, you're quite right.
I've known President
Biden for over 40 years
and it's been a close friendship.
We don't always agree, we often disagree,
but it's instructive to say,
I think he's a self-described
Zionist, pro-Israel,
and I don't think that's
an inaccurate description.
I think it's accurate.
I think he has a basic
sympathy for the Jewish state,
although as in any family,
we can disagree and often do.
But I have no doubt about his sentiment
and I trust that that will continue.
And I can also tell you
that in the times of the
Obama administration,
when Mr. Biden was vice president,
he often served as a
channel to try to find,
I would say, a middle ground,
during times of intense conflict.
So the friendship is not a question.
Now, here's what people don't know.
I mean this issue of the
invitation clouds people's views
and actually their knowledge
of what is happening
with our two governments and in fact,
the security cooperation,
the military cooperation,
and the intel cooperation including cyber
is stronger than it's ever
been under our two governments.
I've spoken to the president
a few a few weeks ago
on the phone since then, I
may not go to Washington,
but Washington is coming
here with a steady flow
including the National
Security Advisor, Jake Sullivan
and Secretary Blinken,
and the chief of the CIA,
all of whom I've met, of course.
And the phone calls that are regular.
- The last 15 months have
been the most violent period
in the West Bank in over two decades.
The reason that according
to Israeli officials
is because the Palestinian
authority has lost control
over some areas.
What is your solution for this?
Is it, as some people say, some people
in your government say
to put more Israeli security
services in those areas?
Or is it to strengthen the
Palestinian authority there?
- It's both, but they failed,
the second has failed.
I mean, they failed.
They're stuck in their
own convoluted politics
which is undergoing some convulsion.
But I think you're quite right.
I mean, Northern Samaria has
become sort of a no man's land
at which you've more
and more terror attacks
that emanate from there.
And my policy has been to,
definitely to keep the
Palestinian authority.
I don't want it to dissolve
the way people are talking,
it's simply ridiculous.